welcome everybody todd story chief
communications officer for the clark
county school district
what we'll do is we'll kick things off
with school board president irene cepeda
followed by superintendent jesus chara
and then we'll hear from
representatives from ccea from kasapi
esea and then the police
unions and then we'll go to q a after
that thanks
hello everybody
we are
i'm pretty excited i'm pretty sure the
folks here are excited as well thank you
all for being here um i feel uh
i feel a lot of gratitude for a lot of
the work that has been put in
to
to make
today a reality
um we
we are listening
we hear we hear folks
and i think more than anything we really
want to acknowledge all the amazing hard
work
that has been put in this last
this last academic year and beyond
but we recognize how difficult this last
year was
and in that recognition we want to make
sure that we're also putting
our budgets to the test budgets
that reflect all the efforts that our
teachers our support professionals our
admin have done to really keep our
schools open to keep our schools safe to
keep our schools
spaces for our students to uh thrive in
so with that i'm going to be super short
because our superintendent has the meat
and potatoes of the detail of the of uh
the plan the
well these uh goodness and i forget the
words
our retention bonuses retention um
activities goodness so with that
superintendent jar everybody
thank you trustee cepeda um before i get
started um really like to commend
trustee cepeda on the board this is
not something that is easy to do alone
um as a superintendent in the team but
really a collective effort when you work
together
as a team a lot of great things can
happen for our employees
as we all know i've been very vocal ccsd
has not been fully staffed
since 1994 when we opened up the school
year
school districts across america are
expecting and experiencing teacher
shortages employees and workforce
um this is um been really in
collaboration and part of what we have
been doing collectively as a as a board
and superintendent for quite some time
when we're looking at individual
employee shortages
not too long ago we raised salaries for
our bus drivers
we also looked at our cypress
technicians
moved our administrators our building
principles from 11 month to 12 months
because
the job is a 12-month job so the board
has really worked together with me and
the team
to look at what we need to do as a
district to make sure that our workforce
has been compensated as trustee sepeda
mentioned
our employees the 42 thousand employees
have
done an amazing job
in closing schools
feeding children
taking kids to school
this providing distance education
for the last two years or so and we've
opened schools as a matter of fact had a
great opportunity in celebrating our
grant and i'm going to do so right after
this press conference
so we needed to do something um to raise
our teacher salary and i'll start there
um
to be competitive it's the first time
since 2015 that we have raised i would
say are starting teacher pay
so we are excited in partnering with
ccea
um that we are moving our starting
teacher salary from 43 000
to 50 115
that puts us above
a lot of districts in the west coast
um because we have to be competitive
in really providing our teachers
the compensation that they deserve and
for us to be able to compete because our
kids
deserve
the opportunity to have a highly
qualified
well-compensated educator
so in order for us to attract teachers
to better secure our schools increase
student achievement
reduce class size and improve our
working conditions for them is to
be able to do that
we are committed
to all our employees the board has also
authorized me
to also in provide a retention
um
recruitment bonus for our support
professionals
um that their deal is a little bit
different um we are working on their
health care as well and we are providing
a forty five hundred dollars
retention bonus we are doing a five
thousand dollars for our administrators
and for all our police officers as well
everybody in the organization as i
mentioned the 42 000 employees have done
a remarkable job in keeping this
community
open
um
for our children so the estimated costs
which will come from
some operating dollars
and others from our federal
stimulus i review all the arp
is a total of 165 million dollars
investment that this board has
authorized me
um to be able to negotiate with our all
bargaining units again thank you for
being here um
and thank you for
your interest and i couldn't thank my
partners here um that have been
really intimately working together with
this deal so now i can turn it over to
cca kristen
um from kindergarten teacher i know that
because i just she was part of the
interview process
um with hiring a new principal from
steve shore elementary
thank you so much dr jara um i i'm
absolutely thrilled to be here
um actually i got out of the summer
acceleration a little earlier because i
am doing the summer acceleration program
because i love my kids and i know that's
where i need to be
um so just to kind of give you a little
bit of background about me i'm chris
nygro i'm a kindergarten teacher i've
been in this school district this is the
only district that i've ever worked in
i'm going close to 10 years so and i
have been
loyal to ccsd
um so i i just wanted to say thank you
so much the parties involved and the
collaboration that was done in order to
get this
this hammered out i know how intense and
i know how stressful it can be but just
to have the ability to really take a
step in the right direction and and get
that recruitment and that retention
that's huge we're talking we have over
300 000 students here in clark and every
single one of them is deserving of a
solid educator and i really feel that
this package that we have is going to
take us there
one of the reasons and or why i feel
like that is for the um retention just
in general i mean we're talking about a
five thousand dollar um using that that
one time state money to get that five
thousand dollars into the hands of our
licensed educators already and then also
really moving that that
base pay i mean we are so competitive
right now on the western side of the
united states talking about moving it to
um 50 115 i believe dr jarrah said
that's huge right that's a really big
deal for new educators coming in
especially inflation's really our
housing market the whole nine yards and
that really has an effect
um so i i really feel also bringing up
that um
the salary up to where we can earn up to
101 000 i mean annually that's a big
deal and i am a dedicated very very
tenacious person and i will get there
and i guarantee that will happen because
that's who i am
um but again i just wanted to say thank
you to the collaboration that was done
between the clark county school district
and the clark county education
association
i know how how tough it is but the
importance again to bring in these
licensed educators to clark
every single one of these kids that are
in our building no matter where their
level are what walk of life they come
for or from they deserve to have the
best and we can bring the best and i
really do feel with what we have right
now that that's going to happen
so
with that being said again thank you
um and i'm going to turn it over to
esea
thank you
hi everyone that's a tough act to follow
sorry my name is jan giles i am the
president of the education support
employees association and together with
jason gately with the teamsters union
we represent uh 12 000 support
professionals in ccsd and we'd like to
thank superintendent jarrah cfo jason
goudy and the trustees for providing
this attention additional retention
bonus and the additional contribution to
the support professionals health
insurance this enables the employees to
not come out of pocket for their health
insurance renewal this september
we greatly appreciate the
acknowledgement of all the hard work
from our
support professionals
and we understand the difficulties in
recruiting and retaining employees and
this is a great incentive thank you
thank you
good afternoon everybody isaac stein
proud principal of desert pines high
school
so thanks for being here today and
thanks for having this event here it's
it's an important and epic moment for
clark county school district i'm also
the treasurer for the executive council
in kasapi so i'm here
to represent kassapi and we can't thank
the board and the superintendent and his
team enough for this collaboration and
working with us on this collaboration
being a resident of clark county for 23
years
and coming here to teach i know this is
an opportunity for us to recruit the
best teachers support personnel and
administrators and this may be that
that effort to get us over the hump and
working to
make sure that we have all the best
teachers at our school so we can't thank
everybody enough we know this incentive
means something this retention bonus
means something to all of us as we know
so many of us are doing the heavy
lifting especially our teachers and
support personnel that do the heavy
lifting every day to make sure that we
support our students and we're looking
forward to this is one way of letting
everyone know how appreciative we are of
their hard work and their efforts and
look forward to the work we're going to
do over the next couple of years thank
you
so um
in closing um and we we can answer any
questions um that you may have we'll be
releasing the details this afternoon
uh the board will be voting on it on the
ninth i just the reason we're here where
desert pines is one of our schools that
has the highest number of vacancies um
and i say that um and it has no
um really
i would say
indication of the school this is a
phenomenal school it's a great school
but it's a number
that we're here to to really identify
every child in the school district
deserves
a highly compensated
and quality teacher
but we we had to take a huge step
forward um in in working together
this is i would say in the middle of our
work and compensating our employees um i
talked about it when i started my my my
conference but i i just go back to
um when i got here um four years ago in
the relationship that we have with all
our bargaining units and i say that
publicly across the board when i speak
to my colleagues we open our schools
with all my bargaining partners
beside our beside together behind me to
say we have to do what's best for kids i
have a great relationship with them but
that's because i have a board and
working together that has made this a
priority
for our employees so
thank you
to all of them and i'm looking forward
to opening up august 9th closing out
summer acceleration and starting august
9th with a great school opening so i'll
here answer any questions that you may
have before i'm going to just be be
mindful because i got to get to another
graduation to anticipate and i have to
get to a graduation tiffany
and police officers here um what about
any additional retention bonuses for
teachers mentioned before but they were
saying that was
so um well we let me let me clarify a
couple things so the the teacher salary
is the one that's going up um to 50 000
um per year everybody else is getting
the bonus on the retention bonus the
teachers
that are not part of the increase in in
in salary is they're going to get the 5
000 retention as well so we also made a
movement at the end that's what you hear
that we also made a movement at the end
on their last column
because it was also important to retain
our teachers and i think it's our board
my board and and my team we felt that it
was important again this is not only
recruitment but also a retention making
sure that our educators stay with us
no the teachers that do not move
get a they do not move up up in their
salary schedule get the five thousand
dollars
rosia
i'm sorry low rate sorry
correct
i felt it was competitive it needed to
be when we looked at the analysis the
ones that are a little bit over over 50
000 obviously are in california
and and i think when you look at the
cost of living it puts us at a better
salary structure than my colleagues
across
across the mountains
the on the 5000 it was agreed upon in
september we'll put it out in two
payments it's a it's a retention so
they'll get it in in september i don't
know the exact date and then in may
no it's related to the number of
vacancies we have
um you know when we're looking at the
number of vacancies that we have
this is why this was important to get it
done
now
yes it is
there's we're we're working and and mr
valadina is here yes and we're also
working
this is a first immediate crisis
and i'd say
a teacher
shortage that we're dealing with but
then obviously going back to the table
and address all the salary schedules as
a board that's that's kind of where
we're headed
up in the future
it was inc this is part of the collab
collaborative salary for me
as superintendent it was important to
get over the fifty thousand dollars
correct if they're retiring they've
already retired yeah
they they thank you trust dissipator
they received the last bonus which was a
thousand dollars last may
we did we already raised um in in
partnership with esea and the teamsters
we already increased their
um salary already we did that i would
say about a month ago and and i'm going
to tell you
um it's going well
i'm hoping that i'm hoping that we feel
um that we fill all our classroom
vacancies when you looked at not only
across you know colossal western i know
that
locally we have some choice
opportunities
that i know that hopefully this recruits
some of our teachers that are in nevada
and clark county
up in our charter schools that may look
at this and and look at this investment
that this board is making um that this
is the place to come to
work in the right direction
plenty of things
fine there's plenty there's still plenty
of things that need to be addressed
however
um
to the superintendent's point it's a
step in the right direction so
we know that their
teacher recruitment retention is a
complicated
it is a complicated piece there's so
many pieces to it and it's multifaceted
so it's this one thing will help but
it's not the only thing we're planning
on doing
and let these
people know hey there's
yeah no thank you thank you for the
question and i think this is
you know sharing the news what we're
doing today we're
again doing some other great things um
you know showcasing and working with our
building principles of the re you know
looking at
my new chief of hr starts tomorrow
we have a new chief of hr that is an
experienced executive that's going to
come in
and and look at
some of the work that we have to do
around supporting our educators you know
we have also invested in instructional
materials
for our educators in professional
development what we are partnering is
looking at what are the learning and
teaching conditions that we have to
address and this is part of the
collaboration efforts that we're doing
uh working together with with our our
union yeah and if i could add because to
the recruitment piece now we we have to
think about the long-term like the
long-term pipeline right so we have our
cte teaching and training program that
does amazing phenomenal work uh in
training future teachers and that is
again district in collaboration with our
nevada system of higher education so all
those pieces again it is going to take a
whole lot it is not this is the one
thing we're doing it is a whole lot of
ands we're and this and this and then
and this so uh those are also
something that you know the district is
collaborating with one more question
with a little spanish as well
and
did i do okay
okay thank you i got to get to a
graduation at uh at the orleans so i
appreciate all of you being here